hey what's going on it's bill bird it's
time for the Monday morning podcast -
Monday June 6th 2016 this is like the
fifth [ __ ] time I tried to start this
thing because I don't know I just had an
aborted landing well I didn't have one
the pilot had one and I was riding in
the back in the allottee I do what we
landed safely you know some airplane
didn't clear the runway that's my fifth
one that I've had I've had five aborted
landings and that was my second one at
LAX first one was vehicle on a runway
and this next one a guy didn't plane was
still on the runway didn't clear it or
whatever but a little less scary now
that I've flown a little bit you know
not a lot but a little bit but uh you're
still in the back and you can't see
what's going on so that's that's always
nice
alright so people been asking me
they've been emailing me they've been
twittering me they've been facebooking
me about what's going on with these
Irish dates Dublin July 31st Belfast
August 1st in Galway Galway modal
Ireland on the 2nd of August all right I
have the pre-sale information but for
whatever reason I'm not allowed to
announce it but I'm going to and I got
to tell you when I went announcer I'm
going to announce it on 6 9 16 at 4:00
p.m. GMT time whatever that means Gaelic
Gaelic mounting 282 times alright why
can't I just say when the [ __ ] this
shit's going to be alright June 10th is
when they're going on sale I'll announce
the pre sale on the 9th I'll [ __ ] this
I'm going to tell you everything now
alright six nine sixteen at four pm the
pre-sale will be announced now right not
just this is why and re-recorded this is
so [ __ ] confusing the pre-sale for
Dublin Island is going to be June 10th
my birthday 2016 at 9 a.m.
Gaelic Mountain Time all right and then
the regular on sale is going to be June
13th 9:00 a.m. GMT time whatever the
[ __ ] that means
alright and
it Belfast is going to be about five
days later and shows Galway a gay away
Motul Ireland will be like that'll be
June 15th so that's the deal all right
and I'll let you guys know I'll just
I'll tweet about it I'll do all that
[ __ ] so nobody gets [ __ ] out of
anything also there's been a second show
added in London England for August 6
2016 I'll have a link up there for that
and all that [ __ ] alright there you go I
got all the business stuff out of the
way and also go to all things calm be
calm be sick of listening to me we've
got a bunch of the talented people out
there that you can listen to and with
that let's get into the podcast ah did I
travel around sciatica it's still acting
up I'm going to every [ __ ] witch
doctor out here at this point I don't
give a [ __ ]
you know some woman was talking to me
was saying how she got sciatica when she
was pregnant and I was just like he
calling me fat and she laughs he's like
nah she cuz I just I just got it and she
went someplace and she goes they just
kind of lightly just whiffed on my
backside I thought they're really going
to need in there they just kind of
lightly was like what's it nobody's
[ __ ] putting leaves on my butt cheeks
okay what everybody else was before that
but I got to tell you like something
happens with the air pressure when I'm
on a plane the back of my leg it feels
like my hamstrings going to snap so I
got to keep standing up doing my
Vietnamese gambler's [ __ ] squat and I
don't know I'm trying to stretch out the
psoas muscle I'm doing everything I can
to try to keep this thing at bay because
I don't [ __ ] have the time to take
care of it I just don't have to [ __ ]
busy here with writing this filthy
wonderful cartoon which I'm having a
great time doing that bop to episode 6
this week people up to Episode six
writing as far as far as that aspect of
it literally sunk to [ __ ] Rain Man
alright let me take it through my trip
here alright I had some [ __ ] guy he's
like in his early 60s
give me this [ __ ] look like he was
going to punch me in the face to the
point I had to say something to him and
I know you guys are thinking like bill
what the [ __ ] you talking [ __ ] to a guy
63 well I'm gonna be 48 this week so you
know when I was 15 he was 30 so it's not
that bad well we're pretty close right
when I was 10 he was 25 right
you know you think he wouldn't have
picked on me back then is what happened
right so I went down go around the
airport right I got bumped up the
business so I get to go first I get to
go into the lounge right I get to go in
and [ __ ] pour myself some corn flakes
or whatever so I go into the lounge and
there's this [ __ ] guy right he just I
don't know I got on the elevator and he
was there he's kind of in my space but
he was a little oblivious or whatever
right [ __ ] horseshoe level balls and
he dies decides which is always
hysterical to me like dude what the why
you still dying that you think that
makes you look younger so anyways it's
like five and the [ __ ] looks before
5:00 in the morning because that's what
time my flight is and you know I go up
to the lounge and I set my [ __ ] down he
goes his other way I might thinking
about this guy and then I'm walking over
to where the cereal is and so is he
alright like two planes about to land
you know on the same runway I'm in front
of him I have priority so I walk over
there and then I feel him standing way
close too close to me and when I finish
you know I just did a couple of turns
you know the [ __ ] serious and couple
turns of the knob it goes into the bowl
and then I pour some milk in it it
probably took me less than 15 seconds to
do that and when I turned around because
I just felt him I would have turned the
other way if I felt him on my left
shoulder try and look at him and he was
glaring at me showing me all of his
bottom teeth you know he's like that
except he wasn't making that noise but
you know the face you make when you
that's what the bleep looking at me just
glaring at me so what the [ __ ] did I say
to him I just looked on it's like I
remember I said are you I go you are you
all right that's why I said are you all
right
and then he didn't say anything and then
I felt bad like aw man was was he like
one of those old guys when I did that
bit the old man's face was that is at
the beginning of the old man's face you
start glaring it first and then you
gradually gets more scared I have no
idea right like those old people know
that going to hell they're thinking back
on their life and it trying to think
they have enough time to say enough hair
hail marys and they just realize they
can do it yeah they probably said ghosts
and saw those creepy things coming up
from Hell so anyways he didn't say he
thinks so I walk away and I'm thinking
that feeling bad like I'm a knight I you
know I just [ __ ] yelled at that and
yelled the old guy but I kind of gave
him [ __ ] you know so I felt bad then I
went over to sit down and then he gets
his [ __ ] cereal and at this point you
know I'm like like [ __ ] 20 yards away
from this guy sitting down and he
[ __ ] turns around and as he's walking
over to his wife he looks at me and
shakes his [ __ ] head up she was
glaring at me
so later I go to get up to get a [ __ ]
Apple and I knew he was going to be
looking at my looked right over at him
and I can't know what the [ __ ] I did and
then I was like Billy Billy are you
really doing this neither one of you is
going to fight you're both too [ __ ]
old to fight and that's how my trip
started so I should have known that it
was going to be a weird travel
experience ended up getting into
Syracuse that's why I was going the
first night and we played this
minor-league hockey arena and I didn't
know at the time until I got there they
actually filmed that's where they filmed
slap shot a lot of it when they did all
the stuff you know listen to the [ __ ]
song when they were on like he the ice
and everything so that was cool we [ __ ]
the next night we did another one of
those small hockey arenas and that one
they told me that was the place Elvis
was supposed to perform at but he died
the day before that was his next concert
and so they still have all these Elvis
tickets and actually gave me this little
frame thing a couple of Elvis tickets
and then the date that I played there
was really [ __ ] cool
what the [ __ ] that I go after that well
then I went down to Paul I was driving
from Portland back to [ __ ] Albany
who's kidding who I wasn't [ __ ] virzi
was riding ruined this SUV and I was
laying down in the backseat because my
[ __ ] leg was killing me
the shit's really starting to scare me
man like how [ __ ] long is this going
to take I've been dealing with this [ __ ]
since February every time I start to
turn the corner I gotta get on a plane
again so the people who stare at me too
when I stand up on the plane I squat
down I didn't give a [ __ ] and they're
just looking at me I told you the last
time this guy asked me if I was prank
so anyways in the final show last night
was was in Albany but I actually when we
drove from Portland which so many
memories came back when we went over
that bridge when we went over this
bridge in we go from New Hampshire to
Maine and I Mumbai used to [ __ ] one
of my first girlfriend used to live over
there we're on the other side of that
but wishing Olivia she lived down the
Boston air but she had like family up
there remember going up all over that
bridge I always think of that [ __ ] I
always think about the ticket that I got
on the [ __ ] Turnpike up there driving
my piece-of-shit truck back the comedy
connection up there all of that [ __ ] and
I got to tell you that just living out
here in LA like all people in New York
Vermont New Hampshire and Western Mass
in Maine I hope they realize how [ __ ]
lucky they are to live where it rains
and there's all that lush land
I'm so [ __ ] jealous of that [ __ ] like
when I came back we when we were driving
from Portland to Albany I actually went
down to the Boston area to visit some
family and friends and stop off one of
my favorite pizza places and I think we
can't ended up coming down Route one and
then [ __ ] memories that were coming
back it was a strip club up there there
was the hilltop steakhouse which they've
now completely knocked down I hope that
sign because it's still up that John
[ __ ] cactus I hope somehow like that
thing is protected you know what I mean
you know it's funny that's like one of
those dumb things they'll sell on
[ __ ] eBay for like a million bucks
and they'll say like 15 people are
watching this you know do you not like
to like back in the day how they used to
they used to catch people with warrants
they would just have like during like a
fight or something they would just
advertise hey you're the other 20th
person to order this come down here and
claim your free gift make all these
people up and they would all got out and
claim the gifts and it'd be all these
people standing around down there then
the cops are just walking and they'd
[ __ ] arrest everybody they should
[ __ ] do that what would dumb [ __ ]
like that on eBay like the giant the
hilltops steakhouse right there's 15
people watching it those 15 people
should immediately be audited who deaf
who do [ __ ] got a million bucks to blow
on a giant lit up cacti mean everybody
wants it
well not everybody I'd love to have that
[ __ ] thing you know get yourself to
spread out in the middle of nowhere you
have a giant lit up cactus your friends
come over right just make a right at the
giant cactus you know you get a nickname
out of it Oh cactus crazy [ __ ] crazy
but nobody has the money to do that [ __ ]
right like I went on eBay right and I
was uh what the [ __ ] I was looking I was
trying to you know kill the flight now
now you can you know go online so I was
just looking up random [ __ ] like
humidors even though I've gotten cigars
mostly out of my life I was just looking
them up because I think that [ __ ]
cool right well I know I was doing I was
looking at cigar aficionado and they had
all these you know cool places where you
can smoke a cigar they let you know in
different cities like places to smoke
and [ __ ] right like I just found a cool
place in London possibly to smoke we'll
see and that is if I smoke that out
we'll figure it out anyways and that
just got me thinking about cigar smoking
and all that type of [ __ ] so I went on
eBay and a lot of the [ __ ] that comes
along with cigar smoking is pretty
[ __ ] cool a lot of the lighters a lot
of the ashtrays and the humidors and I
like looking at
especially if they ventured you're old
so I look at vintage humidor I'm sure
it's still there and this is this is
[ __ ] I think it's Sitting Bull it's
this bust of Sitting Bull alright that's
what the [ __ ] humidor is it's a bust
of Sitting Bull and what's really
[ __ ] you know weird is to you know
put your cigars in it you basically take
off the scalp which I thought was a
little [ __ ] tacky but granted it's
old that was considered a like totally
fine back in the day right so anyways
this [ __ ] thing is going for a
million and a half dollars and it has it
says like there's like 20 people
watching I'm looking it up right now Eva
calm all right
okay vintage humidor boom alright what
do you got what do you got um [ __ ] where
the hell is it coming oh there it is
right there
Sitting Bull cigar store Indian statue
antique American folk art vintage
tobacco
you know it's funny from the side it
actually looks cool from straight on it
just looks like I don't know it's kind
of looking off big it kind of looks said
nothing I don't understand why this
thing is a million and a half bucks
there's 61 people watching this 61
people have a million and a half dollars
to spend on a [ __ ] humidor I don't
know like that's the type of [ __ ] right
there like if I was [ __ ] dodging
taxes and all that type of [ __ ] you know
go out and do this on the internet right
I don't know that's like whenever you
ever watch those Meachem car auctions
you know somebody spends 500 mustang I
mean you're either we're either evading
taxes or you're a wife beater
one or the other okay you're either
cheating the [ __ ] system or your wife
is scared to death of you that she shall
let you [ __ ] do that blow a million
and a half bucks on a humidor look at it
honey
in a great setting ball look at the top
of his head comes off
like after a [ __ ] autopsy anyways so
I came over the hell I was talking about
here also we have him just having this
great anytime I work with Rosie we have
a great [ __ ] time when we're up in
Portland after the show we had a great
time working in the the Elvis venue
there and we didn't have growing up to
this bar afterwards and Game three of
the Stanley Cup Finals and the UFC
fights were both on it Jesus Christ Dan
[ __ ] Anderson do you guys see that
knockout
that was like some Bourne Identity [ __ ]
he threw a kick went past the guy and
then [ __ ] threw an elbow like he was
training in a phone booth I've never
seen anything like that they were
running a long time ago I saw a UFC
fighter basically throw a left hook but
he did it with his knee he [ __ ] got
rocked in the head I think was that guy
used to call the little bottle little
ball I hate the hell is his knee one of
my favorite fighters back then right he
had hair dyed like bright red fire
engine red and he got rocked and he
started to go down and the other guy was
so excited to jump on him start hitting
him that he kind of just went in with
his hands down a little bit and the
[ __ ] guy was able to regroup and he
just I can't explain it he threw it he
need the guy in the head but he like
came from the side he threw a hook this
[ __ ] guy went down gave him the old
right there Fred with the left knee Dan
Anderson the same [ __ ] thing this guy
was just he was getting punched in the
head repeatedly and everybody the bars
going uh right and I'm yelling and I
actually for once because I don't know
[ __ ] about fighting oh he's [ __ ]
eating those punches I look at him and
then X 2 guy in the [ __ ] head he
kicked him in the head and then somehow
he was like parallel to the guy's head
and it gave me a left hook in there with
the elbow and the guy just went down
that was it over and then the coolest
thing ever was his family was there you
know tell me you don't have the coolest
dad ever guy go shirtless in the ring
each
[ __ ] twelve punches to the head and
then knock the other guy out you know
you know it's funny he was in better
shape than his kids he's a 45 year old
guy you should have the dad but he's up
there shredded his kids are coming up
you know he's making them look soft not
saying it was soft I'm just saying
usually by the time you 45 you had three
four kids you just got that 600 yard
stare like you don't give a [ __ ] if
you're eating a Twinkie or a [ __ ]
tube sock you know and this guy's out
there just was shredded so once again
once again UFC completely worth the
[ __ ] money be paid to get in I missed
all the others oh no I saw the the
championship one with a guy via that
I've been watching ever since he was on
The Ultimate Fighter the guy from
Manchester England [ __ ] I got to get his
name here god damn it you know I
realized when he won I've been saying
his last name wrong forever
UFC champ Manchester here we go
what's his name Michael Bisping I wish I
was busy bein Michael Desmond he [ __ ]
won that was another great one what a
night and then as we and as were
watching that simultaneously they
watching well I guess I was probably the
only one really watching it but I was
watching the Penguins San Jose and I'm
looking at this [ __ ] going like holy
[ __ ]
it's two to one they're carrying the
play and all of a sudden they get a high
stick I think it was a four minute power
play they seemed like they were on the
power play for [ __ ] ever
long story short throw up to two to one
in the game and it was like they killed
off like all all [ __ ] 20 minutes of
this penalty seemed like a 20 minute
penalty right they kill this [ __ ]
thing off there's like two seconds left
and all I'm thinking in my head is if
they kill off this penalty they're going
to win this game and they're going to
win the Cup this is the [ __ ] series
and it's over three two score out of
nowhere I don't know I don't know if it
was tipped or whatever after San Jose's
goalie made this one a sickest be
[ __ ] like saved it with like the
inside of his forearm you know a few
minutes earlier then and he let that one
going a little bit of a float
and now it's two games to one right and
I don't give a [ __ ] either way my team's
out of it and then my surrogate team is
also a lot of it all I know is that
means that there's going to be at least
one more game of hockey right as far as
rather than just going for games little
go five right so we at least got two
more games which is good for me because
when when the NHL and the NBA seasons
and I have like a sort of sports panic
attack because they haven't watched been
watching baseball I don't know what the
[ __ ] going on in baseball but all I
know it's like the middle of the season
you know Dahlia is a rubber game just
not all outside you can see that slider
a lot this afternoon
you know after you just went from like
watching people win championships and
playing at that level that's why the NFL
is the [ __ ] as far as like it can
actually compete with October baseball
because you figure that the middle of
the NFL season would be boring like most
most sports the middle of the season is
boring when you plane like 80 to 162
games but NFL only plays 16 games every
game means so [ __ ] much you know Plus
Tom Brady ought to be coming back from
his nice rest a nice rest relaxed pissed
off Tom Brady coming back to light you
up again you know you guys can look
under the rocks and try to figure out
what he's doing someday someday you will
admit that he [ __ ] with you no guy
was just the [ __ ]
and then the saddest thing obviously the
weekend was was the death of Muhammad
Ali man I'm that guy if you've never
watched when we were Kings I used to
watch I used to own that thing and I
still wore it out ahead of on VHS and
had on a DVD I just I've watched it so
many [ __ ] times I just I don't know
how to put the guy in the words it was
literally like whenever I watched it I
was like I have not done [ __ ] with my
life the guy was unbelievable and I
tweeted you know greatest of all time
greatest athlete ambassador human being
of all time and all these you know
Twitter [ __ ] cumo bill he just he's
hit things in a ring like no he didn't
he didn't he did so much stuff beyond
that like you know if that's how great
mom and I leave was like when I said
greatest human ever I said really
they're like better than Ghandi and it's
like exactly exactly
if I said [ __ ] Tom Brady you know
greatest ever you just going to bring up
other quarterbacks you had to bring up
[ __ ] Gandhi this is a goddamn athlete
that's a good comparison because he was
doing Gandhi [ __ ] outside of the ring
and he could knock out anybody in the
world the guy could hold court and the
poorest of the poor right up to the
White House when he walked in he lit up
the room everybody shut up and you never
forgot it and and on top of that he was
one of the greatest fighters of all time
if not the greatest
and I got so much out of when I used to
watch that you know when he was talking
all that [ __ ] it was like he was almost
as much as he was talking [ __ ] he was
like it was like self-help it's not the
way it's done today we're today it's
just all like it's all perverted you
know what I mean it's like you know
what's going to happen if you say the
crazy [ __ ] you know that you hype in the
fight you know that you're going to get
a sneaker deal you know all this money
is coming I'm not saying that he didn't
know that on some level but the [ __ ]
that that guy went through if you want
some of those early especially ones that
are black and white the [ __ ] white
reporters are so goddamn racist it's
like ridiculous I remember he's just
going and going and going and this
reporters gets white guys getting
[ __ ] mad he just hates his confidence
this guy's like if this guy could have
got sent into the future he'd be a hater
on Twitter so he finally just goes do do
you ever stop talking and he said
something like no because I'm knocking
out all bums and if you keep talking I'm
knocking you out too and he just it was
the greatest he just [ __ ] piss the
guy off and he knew what the guy was
doing and he was able to navigate all
that I know everybody says all the
terrible [ __ ] that he did to Joe Frazier
but nobody gets out of this life without
some bad [ __ ] everybody's done some bad
[ __ ] you know what I mean but
I don't know man he still had a good run
of 70 74 years I used to watch him when
I was a kid man
that's how [ __ ] old I am that's
what's freaking me out now is all these
people that were like in the 20s and 30s
when I was a kid and now dying of like
[ __ ] old age and [ __ ] David Bowie
Muhammad Ali [ __ ] freaking me out you
know to me maybe that's why that guy at
the at the little cereal thing in the
[ __ ] at the airport was giving me
that look because he knows he's going
soon you know everybody he knew is
probably all dead right and he's
thinking island gets so much time left
to get cereal you know I was also
thinking the fact that he felt so
[ __ ] like his a little bit like the
complete lack of patience that he had
and I don't have patience the fact that
he couldn't wait two seconds for me to
get some [ __ ] Cheerios I was also
thinking like that's probably why he's
in this lounge this guy just [ __ ]
hate doesn't take no for an answer he's
a lunatic
I don't let's kind of [ __ ] depressing
[ __ ] that would be talking about death
because I got to tell you about my like
the amount of [ __ ] people that have
died in the last goddamn year that I am
old enough to have been a teenager and
seeing them in their [ __ ] prime how
about that print [ __ ] huh another person
lost to the opiates and stuff I just
can't believe I as I can't believe it
but the fact that they actually come at
him and they come at Fame and celebrity
and all that type of [ __ ] like people
are [ __ ] dying regular people are
dying because of that drug other the
[ __ ] you say fentanyl or whatever the
hell it is they get it then the
prescription runs out they're addicted
to opiates and then they get on heroin
and the fact that they don't talk about
the pharmaceutical companies at all is
because that's like a hundred fifty
[ __ ] zillion dollar business and they
give money to the politicians and they
advertise on TV so they make like prints
out to be like this
this famous guy that you know nobody
could say no to I mean I might be wrong
on this but I know he had at least one
hip replacement if not to and if you
ever watched the guy the guy never took
a show off he was all over the [ __ ]
stage I imagine he was in pain and
that's how that [ __ ] started was
basically him porn is hot on stage
giving everybody a hundred percent he
wore out his [ __ ] hips what's this
James Brown did the same thing he had to
get new hips fortunately by the time
Prince got the operation hopefully they
were further along and but I imagine he
still had all kinds of pain and then
that's that's my guess but the fact that
people came at him some people the way
that they came at him was I don't
consider in the shows and the music that
he left us that that was really [ __ ]
a little below the belt oh when you say
I I think that's a little below the belt
if you guys seen this YouTube video my
name is John Baker you got to watch this
thing I apologize because it's going to
be in your [ __ ] head for the rest of
time I'll post the video to a my Twitter
account he's singing he's singing a
Maury and he can't remember how to
ability over I can't stop watching this
guy this guy I swear to god I think it's
his first TV gig somebody was sick I
think they say at the beginning so this
guy fills in and if you look at him he's
literally having an out-of-body
experience so it's so funny to me
because I can relate to this person
because the first time I did stand-up I
felt like I was watching myself I [ __ ]
everything up and this guy just away
says his name
it's almost he just he says like my name
is John Baker yeah it's like like he was
outside I think that might be my
favorite part of the video is when this
[ __ ] guy just the way he says his own
name he didn't say my name is John Baker
he goes my name is John Baker I did it
right the first time and I just [ __ ]
it up you got to hear this
yeah this [ __ ] guy he says he's
singing all these Jesus songs hang on
hang on [ __ ] ever
my name is John teak it's like he's
watching his life like he already died
and then he came back he just got to
like he first time you ever realized my
name my name is Jon Baker that's my
[ __ ] name and this is my life and I'm
on TV and I'm going to sing this song
this is what I did with my life me you
look at the guy [ __ ] poor best
anyways it's dak er see if you're just
listening now you want to [ __ ] watch
it at work oh my god listen to him sing
Alleluia
ah damn before the grace of God this
[ __ ] guy would be the most
interesting interview ever just like
he's one of the most fascinating people
I've ever seen like what the what is
going on in between those [ __ ] ears
right now I think if they could you
could make a show about his [ __ ]
thoughts you know all these [ __ ]
movies though it's yeah you know they
show the movie but it's done in Reverse
and then they try to [ __ ] flip you
out nothing nothing Pink Floyd could
ever [ __ ] write can match what's
going on in this guy's head highly
recommended all right let's read um
let's read some little bit a habitation
ye bells will ring ring good thing good
thing that's a little more er um what
the [ __ ] is a goddamn my name is Jon
Baker all right Oh me undies biondi's no
more sweaty taint blue suit me undies me
undies is so dry you're gonna faint and
fall into a puddle dick [ __ ] first
but don't [ __ ] worry your underwear
will absorb it just like one of those
pamper commercials throw it into the
ocean oh yeah kill a bunch of [ __ ]
dolphins all right me undies everybody
whether you're wearing a suit or sweats
you spend almost 24 hours a day in your
underwear but instead of making a
statement like Superman's tights under
everyday clothes your problem your
underwear is probably boring the undies
is here to change that
every pair of me undies is made from
sustainably sourced modal mold al well
I'm going to keep saying this until you
tell me which one to accent right it's
like a one syllable word like bike you
know bicycle it's on the set
crying I was on the bike I'm [ __ ] up
anyways every pair of my undies is made
from sustainably sourced modal Oh
a fabric that's twice as soft as cotton
I'll tell you right now John Drake I
didn't have on me undies even if he did
not even modal could [ __ ] absorb the
sweat pouring down his [ __ ] balls
nothing can describe to fit the fields
of me undies tlme undies don't want you
to try them on you'll understand while
they're called the world's most
comfortable underwear please somebody's
Illuminati probably as boxers made out
of an endangered species right baby seal
[ __ ] briefs and if you don't love
your first pair of me undies they're
free no questions asked me undies has
dozens of styles and limited edition
prints to help you make a statement with
your underwear some freaks going to
collect those whether anyone sees them
or not remember Superman shipping is
free in the US and Canada and you can
save up to $8 a pair with me undies with
me Vimy undies subscription plan get the
subscription plan or a single pair get
20% off your first order when you go to
my undies calm / / that's me undies calm
/ / for 20% off your first order first
order ok neocon cipher alright always
shave club over there people Dollar
Shave Club really appreciates you buying
all this [ __ ] I don't read this stuff
when they say III Dollar Shave Club comm
delivers amazing razors right to your
goddamn door for a third of the price of
what the greedy razor corporations
charge that means when you join Dollar
Shave Club geek you can afford to shave
with a fresh blade anytime you want
which feels fantastic you can get a
fresh shave first class ship whenever
you use the executive blade and that's
without even hurting your wallet and
when you use the executive with their
doctor copies easy shave butter dr.
Carver's shave butter Carver's shea
butter the blade gently glides across
your face for the smoothest shave ever
shave butter isn't your average shape
for full
pree yeah shake cream it's a unique
conditioning formula with high quality
natural ingredients leaving your skin
unbelievably soft and smooth now is a
great time to join Dollar Shave Club new
members who buy a tube of shave butter
get a month of the executive razor for
free take advantage of this special
offer today today today it's available
by going to dollarshaveclub.com / /
that's dollarshaveclub.com / / o is
another one LegalZoom everyone asked at
these other way alright LegalZoom
attention to detail is critical when you
own a business that's why you should use
Legal Zoom they can take care of the
legal details so you can focus on
growing your business
you already know Legal Zoom is a great
way to start your business they've
helped over a million people get set up
the right way not the wrong way the
right way there's more to running your
business and getting started supplier
and customer contracts come with the
territory and if you need to hire help
each state has its own employment laws
what a pain in the ass is don't spend
valuable time researching the laws and
reading small print let LegalZoom handle
that part they have a network of
independent attorneys licensed in 48
states who know your local laws and
regulations they'll provide the legal
answers for your day-to-day questions
the best part is you don't pay by the
hour since Legal Zoom isn't a law firm
instead you pay a low monthly fee and
know exactly what you're getting upfront
so go to legalzoom.com
today and spend your time growing your
business instead of worrying about legal
details use bu our our bure in the box
at checkout to save even more in
legalzoom.com I don't get why they say
well we're not a law firm but we're
going to give legal advice we're not
going to charge further by the hour like
lawyers do but we have a team of lawyers
no [ __ ] zigzagging all over the track
they're all right stamps.com trips to
the post office have become second
nature to you they seem easy because
you've been doing your mailing and
shipping that way for so long but think
about all the hassle
man dropping what you're doing driving
they're finding parking parking getting
stared at at the cereal place by some
weirdo with dyed hair despite the fact
these bald there's a much better way
stamps calm pants calm is the easy and
convenient way to get postage right from
your desk buying print official u.s.
postage using your own computer and
print with stamps calm there's no
guesswork they make it easy to exact
post to get the exact postage for any
letter any package any class of mail the
instant you need it no expensive postage
meters to leased and no more trips to
the post office you got to try it I use
stamps calm to send out all my posters
whenever I'm whoring myself out after
shows sign up to stamps commie use my
last name bar for this special offer for
week trial plus 110 dollar bonus offer
that includes postage in a digital scale
so don't wait go to Stan's calm before
you anything else your baby's going to
cry don't worry about just going to
stamps calm click on the microphone stop
the homepage and type in birth at Stan's
calm enter bar all right got it out of
them [ __ ] away here we go let's get
back to the podcast
[Music]
alright let's read some of the letters
for this week riggan elites in Loretto
before before I do though the Jesus
Christ poor Jason law head man after
Game one he's a Cleveland guy after Game
one I can't say game on after the first
[ __ ] quarter this guy was sending me
text the editor gets head in the oven
I'm like Jesus Christ dude nobody
[ __ ] throws in the towel the way you
did I remember back to back years I
think in 84 the Lakers came out and blew
out the Celtics in game 1 and we came
back and beat him and then the very next
year we blew them out in game 1 won by
like 15 20 [ __ ] points and then the
Lakers won so I was like the [ __ ] sakes
the Bruins went down oh - to Vancouver
we ended up winning for the next five
and we raised we [ __ ] hoisted up the
cup stop being such a negative Nelly and
then after the game - when they lost by
like [ __ ] 30 or 35 I wrote back to
him I maybe you got a point yeah
I never say this after two games but
this series is [ __ ] Oh
it's over man just go go down if you
live in Oakland just go [ __ ] find a
you know find a good spot for the
championship parade this this is I don't
know maybe they go back to Cleveland the
ring you know all the positivity from
their fans see Pinto I'm kidding
is a question I got a few guys I didn't
get why Trump got into so much [ __ ]
trouble you know like we know what I
know because he's a dope but like this
stuff that they were saying that he said
something racist right about the judge
mexican-american judge right something
about the [ __ ] wall this is what I
like to do on a hot-button issue like
this I'm just going to wait right in but
barely even know in the facts says
Donald Trump's attacks on the judge are
racist he's quite literally saying the
judge can't do his job because of his
ethnicity this is the definition of
racism I guess he was doing some debate
going on about that wall that he wants
to build and this judge who's
mexican-american was going to rule on it
and I think Trump said that he didn't
want him to because he was Mexican he
was going to be biased so everybody said
that that was racist so here's my
question
as Joe 12-pack I'm not Joe Sixpack Joe
12-pack basically what he did there as
far as I could tell is how they pick
juries isn't that how they always pick a
jury you know what I mean like if you go
down for jury duty and the defendant is
black as a white dude yet the I'm not
I'm not going to get picked for this
jury or the defending defendant attorney
doesn't want me on there right there's
not how they pick the whole Oh Jess how
they always do it if it's a domestic
violence case let's try to get as many
women there as possible you know I think
they hide if I go because I think that
they can understand women also now
they're hoping to win the [ __ ] case
so what they do is they stack the deck
with enough people of the same ilk as
the defendant right now don't they do
that
am i nuts here I believe that that's
what they do so I thought it was kind of
ironic that they within the court system
that if Trump is saying that it's like
Trump's picking his jury to try to get
the [ __ ] wall and what he wants is he
wants a bunch of [ __ ] white people
who like a white guy goes over but it
could be greater good you watch out
great it's going to be like
he wants the mouth-breathing morons that
like him on his jury that's all he was
saying as far as I could tell right not
saying the guy's not racist but I
thought that that one they was
stretching the bounds a little bit now
I'm just asking a [ __ ] question here
before you [ __ ] edit this thing and
make me look like the next Hitler but I
was watching that story I was just going
like yeah that's kind of how courts work
it's kind of exactly how it works and
not to mention when the OJ verdict came
in white people like what the [ __ ] if
black people are freaking out having a
parade that's why they do it right
everybody watches it and you put
yourself in the position of whoever's
there I watched the OJ trial I'm [ __ ]
I got my throat slashed right
black people watch it I go yeah I got
off that's how I look at it I don't know
and I don't think that's wrong either
it's like watching sports except it's
people's freedom anything all right
Scandinavia hey Billy birbal's is it
true that you're not going to come to
Scandinavia me and my lady are huge fans
and was really hoping for you to come to
Sweden this summer slash fall I just
need to know if I need to book some
plane tickets to the Netherlands then
this is going to cost me like 1 grand
for us to see your [ __ ] but I'll bet
it's worth it but I just need to know if
you're playing to come to Scandinavia
some point in the future otherwise love
your [ __ ] and looking forward to after
some family season - well thank you very
much um Epis a family season - is the
reason why on this trip
I'm not going to Scandinavia so like
there's like
three chunks okay there's the my pasty
people which is coming in first you know
just like the jury does this mean I'm a
racist the way I'm touring against other
white people it's just how it worked up
and then I probably we do the
Scandinavian thing next and then
hopefully Eastern Europe that's what I
am hoping to do this show takes up way
more time than I thought it would but
like they I had a list of 29 cities that
wanted to bring me over there and I
could have gone on a month-long [ __ ]
crazy ass tour I've broken it up into
two but I think the way my workload is
now I have to break it into three but
like I am absolutely coming back there
again it's a beautiful country I love it
you know who [ __ ] doesn't want to go
that been in like two or three times and
I'll definitely come back I just don't
know when I can't promise you as to when
but I am definitely going to come back
and I don't know other than that I don't
have any more information so save your
money dude don't blow it brand
don't blow grant coming to see me my
[ __ ] and dick jokes I'll come your way
all right don't worry about it okay
x-men billboard hey Billiam um this is
[ __ ] nerd [ __ ] nerd [ __ ] so please
bear with me there's a new x-men movie
and Rose McGowan the chick who used to
date Marilyn Manson has a tits in an
uproar over this billboard because
between mystique a woman and apocalypse
a dude if you don't want to click on the
link from some weirdo you don't don't
know no problem just a picture just
picture a blue dude holding up a naked
blue woman by the throat to the point or
feet aren't on the ground context
apocalypse the dude is a badass villain
in the movie and mystique the woman is
the leading lady and badass heroine in
the movie here's the problem Rose
McGowan says this is promoting violence
against women which I feel is horseshit
here's why if it was Hugh Jackman /
Wolverine being choked out and held
no problem the point of the post is to
show how dangerous / how much of the
threat the villain how much of a threat
the villain is it's not a political
statement here's my issue with this
though how does a studio slash movie
maker win suppose Wolverine was the
leading hero was what women would become
women would be complaining that it's
always a man as the hero and women are
more like backup or support roles I mean
miss mystique is badass she's leading
the fight against this guy to me that's
empowering to women she isn't a sex
symbol in the movie though Jennifer
Lawrence who plays there was really
attractive she's just strong and a
leader all I can think is that they
wanted her standing all I can think is
that they want her standing on the neck
of the villain but this but that's
[ __ ] stupid for promotional posters
you couldn't have her be the villain and
holding up a man hero because that would
be some kind of anti woman all women are
evil campaign instead rightly you lost
me here you couldn't have her be the
villain and holding up a man hero oh I
see if the female character was evil and
then was holding up the guy character
they couldn't do that because then they
would be saying every auntie could be
considered anti women all women are evil
I guess what bothers me is that it just
seems like there's no way to please any
non-white mail lately women wanted a
strong female hero they got one but
she's in danger of the villain a man
somehow that equals violence on women
when it's really just about violence in
general or war or conflict or whatever I
mean the dude isn't slapping her for
over cooking a steak he's trying to
conquer the world she's trying to stop
stop him and he's choking her ass how
how is that a gender issue alright let
me see let me see if I can find the
picture this year I did look at it ah
the dog Lively no that's not always
click on the wrong one
yeah I actually you know when I heard it
I thought it was [ __ ] but then I saw
the poster know the movie with the clip
that I saw I don't see your feet
dangling off of it I see why they did it
I understand why that they did it that
way what happens is when you're right
what I'm learning when you're writing
something you're so [ __ ] focus on is
the story tracking from point A to point
B to Point C and we land this thing
without crashing into the [ __ ] ocean
that they wouldn't think that anybody
you know might have a problem with that
I understand I understand is actually
one of those ones I get why they don't
want to see that but in defense of you
if how about this if the guy character
the the [ __ ] Apollo guy whatever his
[ __ ] name is was apocalypse such dumb
names apocalypse mystique it's all sound
like bad Cologne anyways if if
apocalypse was holding the Wolverine
Hugh Jackman by the throat now would
that be promoting male-on-male violence
would there be more barroom brawls
because of that I honestly don't think
it promotes violence I think like the
level stupid that you'd have to be to
look at apocalypse holding up holding a
woman by her throat and to say like oh I
guess it's okay to hit women now I'm
going to start hitting women if you were
that [ __ ] stupid by the time you got
to you unless she was riding in the car
let's see you driving home and now
you're going to [ __ ] choke her
because you saw this Apocalypse guy
choking a [ __ ] mystique right you'd
also see another thousand signs on the
way home and next thing you know I don't
know you've been a car dealership buying
something or getting a [ __ ]
McDonald's sandwich I think you would
forgive you with that like if your brain
was like that influenced but having said
that looking at the
sorry I don't I understand why they were
just like you know that's not the
greatest image you could have another
image up there yeah I don't have a
problem with them changing it but I
definitely understand your your points
on that thing but you know I don't I
don't [ __ ] know it's it's just the
time that we're living it everybody gets
offended everybody doesn't get offended
a small group of people gets offended
and the news covers it you know because
what are they going to talk about the
[ __ ] how the drug companies in a
roundabout way killed prints you know I
mean what are they gonna talk about
they're going to talk about fracking and
people can [ __ ] up the water supply
Kenny there's too much money involved in
that okay but you know if you got a
group of [ __ ] soccer moms upset about
a [ __ ] blue woman getting held up by
a guy who appears to be made out of
stone in a movie you know that's going
to make it it's going to make it you do
a Caitlyn Jenner joke and a [ __ ]
strip mall yeah that's going to get on
the [ __ ] news but real [ __ ] that
matters now that's not going to happen
you know that's not good well I won them
why would you do that that's just
another one of those back burner stories
that they just stick on the front burner
all the [ __ ] time like they I mean
I'm not saying like you know violence
against women is a major issue but I'm
just saying like people aren't is
simplistic is that like they don't
[ __ ] look at something and like I
don't know is a kid like the amount of
violence that I watched when I was
growing up you know what I mean all the
[ __ ] shows that I've watched I've yet
to chase somebody down an alley pull
them off a fence chain-link fence
beat him up or even slide over the hood
of a car I saw all those images when I
was growing up I used to pretend and
play war and all that [ __ ] I never
[ __ ] killed anybody I've never hit a
woman I never did any of that I think
what you know what it is is what really
makes you do [ __ ] like that is horrific
[ __ ] parents I think that that's what
it is now they're trying to blame the
signs the sign that's going to be up for
all of [ __ ] two weeks when this
movies out as opposed to your dad and
mom and their relationship that you grow
up for the first
years of your life [ __ ] watch it but
you know you can't blame those people
because those people buy things on the
channel you know what I mean so you
always give them a pass and then you rub
their balls and you call them Joe
Sixpack and [ __ ] the true heroes you
know they're always rubbing their balls
like they give a [ __ ] about them they
don't they just want their money you
know I mean that's why corporations act
like all of these non crisises are
absolute crisis crisis disease because
they don't want to lose a [ __ ] dime
so if anybody ditches anybody moans
anybody complains they [ __ ] cave-in
and then a lot of these groups are aware
of that and when they get to get a
corporation to cave it gives them like
it it's almost like a video game it
gives them more life and they're taking
more seriously so it's a giant it's a
giant [ __ ] game you know at the end
of the day it's it's two people that
don't [ __ ] exist but I don't know
there's something there's a look on her
face she doesn't look badass there it
makes me feel bad for her and I want to
help her so maybe what they should have
done she should have had a more [ __ ]
Ronda Rousey look on her face and maybe
was pulling back on his [ __ ] those
cornrows what the [ __ ] does he have was
that wavy hair I can't I don't know what
this guy's made out of his [ __ ]
claymation hair she should have she
should be like you know maybe gouging
his eyes a little bit I don't know that
was kidding no they'd still [ __ ]
complain if you really want to get him
going just have that picture right there
that image not I'm not mean it's how you
do that it gets bad there's no sense of
humor anymore I was going to I was going
to say that maybe you could take that
image and say like no don't bill don't
it's-it's don't ask me to show I'll tell
you what I was going to say all right
hey Billy dope Billy the [ __ ] dope
can't can women forget mr. nice guy
persona hey I'm really on a difficult
weeding today
all right big fan from Lithuania that's
another one on the list that I got to
get to you're a great comedian it would
be great if you ever decided to do you
stand up here in the Baltics
that will happen at some point in my
career hopefully sooner rather than
later
alright the guy says I got it this
dilemma can a woman forget your past as
a nice guy one of my former classmates
is coming back to my home town on summer
vacation for a few weeks and let's say
I'd like to get intimate with her while
she's here now the thing is when we were
still in school I had a mad crush on
this girl for years however [ __ ] didn't
work out because I didn't know how the
life works how the females work and also
I was a little [ __ ] mr. nice guy
I'd beat my younger self that was
possible all right you give your doing
some good therapy here but for over the
years but over the years that I've spent
in our capital city I can safely say
that my view and attitude towards
females and masculinity masculinity has
changed significantly what do you think
can a woman brush off the image of a
nice guy or are you forever marked with
the certain character traits in her eyes
yeah I think your Chi you're kind of
[ __ ] just put it this way like take
like the actor that that played like
Arkell or something like that it's like
you're typecast you know and Oracle
could literally become an army [ __ ]
ranger and then leave the military and
when he went to go do a [ __ ] action
movie they have [ __ ] Oracle give me a
[ __ ] break right it just the problem
is what you got to do look you always
got to take you've always got to take a
bet what you're going to have to do when
you get up there is you're gonna have to
crowd the plate not good which is I
would just be you're gonna have to be
significantly different to raise any
sort of intrigue in her you know what I
mean
because she probably just wants to meet
up with you you know have a couple of
sighters or whatever that whatever those
drinks women have when they know that
they're not going to [ __ ] you you know
one of those [ __ ] I want to feel warm
you know they have a stupid sweater that
covers the
hands - and they drink it with both
hands out of a mug you know and it's
just [ __ ] over right feel like you
know hit more on the waiter than even I
mean listen to you you're gonna have to
like I don't know I don't know what you
got to do go buy yourself a Raiders of
the Lost Ark leather jacket you got to
try to come in and act like you've been
[ __ ] doing so this is a thing this is
what's going to [ __ ] you is you want
this woman too bad all right you got to
not give a [ __ ] don't be don't be a dick
but just go in there and just say what's
going on what even up to you know and
then talk up some of the [ __ ] you're
doing you know I don't know look at your
phone on his broad she's driving me
crazy I got the legs all over me I don't
know I don't know what dude it I don't
know what to tell you on this one
once you're typecast it's [ __ ] over
dude you got to go behind the camera
here you got to start directing or some
[ __ ] because I don't know what to tell
you you're um this is what I would do
just know this going into it you [ __ ]
alright so there's no pressure
who gives a [ __ ] and I don't know make
her laugh and just tell you no I always
had a crush on you but I used to be a
[ __ ] but I'm not a [ __ ] anymore so
what do you say well you say you come
over here and jump on my [ __ ] up you
can't go that way but uh yeah I would um
yeah man that's a tough one that's a
tough one yeah you know maybe that's it
just trash your former self yeah it's
being used to be a [ __ ] you know I
don't know how to do it dude you know
what you get stumped me somewhere in
there I think I think the whole not
giving a [ __ ] and then trashing your
former self and then just telling her
that you had a crush on her who knows
dude maybe uh I don't know
there's a chance maybe she liked you
back then or I don't know women got that
thing they'll do once you're the [ __ ]
friend it's your your it's over dude
so yeah you're [ __ ] called the lovely
Nia Nia you know we need you me and this
guy from Lithuania
I'll tell you really quickly grab grab
one of those cords alright Jesus alright
as your plug in and I'll tell you this
guy basically in Lithuania he used to be
a [ __ ] when it used to be mr. nice guy
so he didn't get anything any of the
nice nicest racing motor would say right
so he whatever he had a crush on this
chick and she got put in the friend zone
as Chris Rock would say I'm just going
to quote every black comedian here and
[Music]
you plugged in there we go and you're
putting a windscreen on and it's really
loud and annoying to the listeners
oh I'm sorry granny the lovely Mia
everybody hi yes so basically he had a
question this girl he was a nice guy he
got put in the friend zone and now she's
coming back to town he's now lived in
the city he understands the male-female
dynamic better and the way he's wearing
this he's been doing all right for
himself but he still wants to bang this
woman he his question is once you're in
the friend zone like that okay is it
possible to get out of it
absolutely it is oh wow okay because I
was going like I don't know I was saying
you're like typecast you're like Oracle
and now you want to be the star of an
action movie you know but ya know I
think you can but it's all it's all
predicated on your behavior like you
don't want how to all of a sudden start
acting like an aloof jerk or anything
like that so I told the bio Raiders of
the Lost Ark waist-length leather jacket
maybe gonna happen in a whip
yes effect is it better I just think
maybe you're a little less available
perhaps you know you know it can be a
thing where she'll come to town and be
like oh my god I could let's go here and
do that I want to do this and it you
know oh yeah yeah yeah definitely well
let me know when you're around yeah
maybe we can grab a drink or something
keep it cash and don't go in there like
oh I've been [ __ ] a lot of broad
Cynthia not like that
but as she's talking about her life you
talk about your life you haven't seen
some girls here and Nana no nothing too
serious but I've been having my fun but
anyway what's going on with you you look
good like that like Nia Ram that was
good Oh were you were you were you
enjoying that Justin and I I'm joining
the advice yeah that was good thank you
I was yes I was stammering I was like
might have to just [ __ ] and I said your
best thing you got going is you know you
got no shot but just don't give a [ __ ]
and just go in there and just be like
nice also sure too
you have to not give it you can't go
into with expectation of anything yeah
you think you're yourself I think you
just be normal be a friend like you have
been but I think I have a friend who
often gets friends owned it and I'm
always telling him that he needs to make
himself less available because he always
makes himself what is that
psychologically to women always when
you're less available by at last theory
and I know it'll be considered sexist so
I'll listen to you I think it's the same
with men and women if you're less
available like the people people want
you more I think that's just how life is
people like the hunt I think men like
the hunt a little more so I think you
should I never like go on really
someone's like a planner be like oh hey
you're not a hunter I look at far
together so I was just more like I just
I hate it when women played hard to get
it was so freitas it got so boring so
[ __ ] fast I was just like I keep
[ __ ] I'll just go rub one out now go
watch a game and then you know something
that I could you're not worth the
[ __ ] trouble right you know what I
mean I just always found that like
because I remember when I would you
start to walk away and let these girls
would be like no you're supposed to blah
blah blah blah them say yeah I didn't I
didn't get the script where am I in like
some [ __ ] awful play right now right
I walked away from a lot by my number
could have been so much higher I go to
chase
chase I just tapped out I'd be like uh
yeah you know if you know what I
understand you know I would [ __ ] me oh
hi oh no don't say that about yourself
people like you alright
a bill dill pickle I love a good
sandwich my question to you is if you
were a sandwich what type of sandwich
would you be I think you already
answered this one you can eat only one
sandwich for the rest of your life what
would you bake all right now remind the
listeners what kind of sandwich you
think I am
I once compared you to a grilled cheese
sandwich but the thing about it is you
were about his exotic is a grilled
cheese sandwich I was talking about that
if if I ever went to prison yes the fact
that was a redhead right on for the
first time of my life I might be
considered exotic yeah I thought you
were grossly overestimating I was joking
about the fact we I would be sexually
assaulted in there and you had to remind
me that I'm a plain Jane there wasn't
even tomatoes on that [ __ ] grilled
cheese sandwich you think with the hair
I would have got something [ __ ]
all right so sandwich would you like to
eat for the recipe I know the sandwich
so I could just sound like this question
came on at Cosmo he was a sandwich what
kind of sandwich would you be if you
could only eat one sandwich for the rest
of your life what would it be we would
never ask each other what kind of
sandwich we'd want to be we'd be like
what kind of dress are you a classic
little black dress a cocktail dress Oh
or a gown for the Oscars like that
what about for the bigger guys what
about for the bigger girls basically not
the bigger girls are you a car cover
with spaghetti straps stop I didn't like
how they just feed your [ __ ] egos
like you're all these pearl yeah when I
get what they're doing they're trying to
sell magazine anyway what kind of
sandwich would you be Velveeta
if I was a pair of pants I'd be clam
diggers I saw like four or five guys
wearing those [ __ ] thinks wow this
weekend
yeah like those guys who have been
Hitler Youth haircut ceman they just
walk her out that chaos up the [ __ ]
air it's the funniest thing ever
I don't know why it's not so sexual just
point their legs and start laughing it's
just me all right I love a good sandwich
- okay
would I be I don't know my freckles and
all that probably a lobster roll lobster
crab roll no you're good all [ __ ]
white with red blotches Dale bun that'd
be my sciatic nerve problem I'm a mess
it sure like there are certain white
people they definitely take on the hue
of a boiled lobster when they head to my
son
that would be me if you kill me a turkey
sandwich because you like turkey
sandwiches yeah but that's not me you're
right no turkey sandwich you know people
get excited they're happy when turkey
comes around you know what I mean I
think you're a turkey sandwich because
you're like well I don't ever say that
again
I think you're a turkey through your
reliable your status and when I talk I
make it go to sleep I think that when
when consumed I make you sleepy all
right if you could only one sandwich me
up for the rest of your life what would
it be it feels like a Lifetime movie is
a Philly cheesesteak considered a
sandwich because you know that's my
all-time favorite of all time well I
mean it's not considered breakfast
no it's considered a cereal all right so
yeah absolutely cheesesteak nope yeah
hero is a sandwich right what it was a
popsicle
yeah yeah a hero sandwich so you know so
I get one sandwich rest of my life I
need a peanut butter sandwich with
butter PBB NJ yes that's what I would
have with a glass of [ __ ] milk wait
you have jelly on it though wouldn't you
know I don't get fat
you put jelly on your own [ __ ] with
you if I gotta have one once we'll just
once the rest of my [ __ ] life I don't
have to eat it every day
mm-hmm well no not every day but the
only sandwich when you're in the mood
for a sandwich you can only eat this
particular sandwich I don't know an
Italian sub
you like Italian sandwiches let me put
the oil all over and it feels like the
bread sweaty you don't always have to
get the oil I don't know what I am I
don't know what I would [ __ ] have
it's just who I know I guess if I
wouldn't die of a heart attack I'd have
a roast beef sandwich there you go there
you go bill you're exciting all right
lady likes the belly Billy you bastard
loved the podcast just funny you bastard
loved the podcast might have been
following your shenanigans for nearly
eight years hustling for tickets when
you get here to London I got my birthday
on the 3rd of August and we'll be
cruising through to your gig on the
fifth I got you a couple years ago and
gave you a cigar after the show at the
Roundhouse in Camden who knows maybe you
smoked at course I did okay so help me
with this kind of weird dilemma of mine
here's the deal I'm six-two six-three
and a good day he's feeling good about
himself stands up straight and I'm
fairly trim however due to my love of
cake pie and all things doughnut I pack
I packed on a mass in one specific area
my belly
oh god that's the classic European
[ __ ] body you know yeah they got
those seventh-grader arms and then they
just got the [ __ ] fish and chips
belly
I generally thinner people but they like
their pugs and they're like yeah
the thinner could I think their food is
higher quality but they just don't go to
the gym over there they walk around a
lot on all right my brother loves it
they've nicknamed me big belly bigsby
call back to Chappelle's Clayton Bigsby
and I've become used to used to giving
it a good old-fashioned slap from time
to time my lady loves it too she rubs it
wants to fill up with her rabbit food
she's vegan whatever it said res cetera
it's a mindfuck subverts the whole guys
got to have a packed vibe you lose them
in here anyways I'm going to keep on
going Michelangelo on this [ __ ] and
getting into shape at the risk of losing
the failsafe laughter of the day what do
you think yeah dude you don't to be the
fat guy who
slaps his belly like a [ __ ] walrus
looking for a mate and if you don't
learn it under control it's going to get
bigger and bigger and it's going to be
bad for your house so trust me your
girlfriend might love the belly right
now but she's going to really love that
six back I really
what if she's insecure she's worried
that he's going to go out and [ __ ]
start it with the full monty someplace
they can both work and get the six-pack
together although she might already have
it since she's a vegan and I'll and know
that never happens and to keep what
couples could never work out
I don't like yeah I'm not into it but
remember we tried to work out and I was
just yelling you push it up member that
no we never worked out together like
that
we are the gym together then we have to
everything as we always do we go to a
party what do we do we go and different
words yeah yeah I came here to have a
good time
nothing not to be with the person I live
with I came here yeah I live with you I
don't need to hang out with you know
what's going on with you in this new
environment all right oh yeah I know
your girlfriend's going to love the
six-pack so keep at it and like to keep
a belly just so people can slap it
around so you can be that guy at the
party after a while yeah that's pathetic
it's better to get shredded and be you
know real Michelangelo yeah then you get
to walk around being a dick being aloof
you know just every time people talk to
you pretend you're looking at something
down the street you [ __ ] eyebrows up
sorry Manish got to keep on moving you
know I'm like a shark did you talk about
that poster uh yeah yeah I missed it
yeah the guy she brought up a bunch of
great points which is well I don't know
if you wanna go back and read it I can't
I don't remember he was just saying like
look at well no if he was like holy is
one that I made a p50 was holding up
Hugh Jackman would that increase the
chances of guys fighting other guys I
don't think it's about like increasing
like influencing people to do what it's
just like it's just not a good well they
said it like it isn't a great look I
actually I don't think that it's a good
poster but I would say that I don't
think it promotes violence against women
I wouldn't think so either but although
I'm not trying to speak for blue women
though right they can speak for
themselves
no I don't know I saw that poster and I
first of all couldn't tell it was a
woman but if I was like well versed in
that whole thing I would be like oh
that's such a such character yeah I know
I don't know but I think it's probably
birthday there on the all the way from
pose there I was saying they're all
named after like discontinued colognes
they're like why mystique apocalypse it
just sounds like it's like whoever came
up with Zima then tried to get into
Cologne and it all [ __ ] bombed right
listen I unfortunately got to stop the
podcast because I gotta go to work well
bump off a little dudududududududu all
right thank you guys for listening and
I'll let you guys know about those
pre-sales for the upcoming dates in
Ireland and thank you to everybody
that's been buying tickets in Scotland
in Amsterdam in London and the second
show in London Nene that's so great yeah
when I saw it it's a gala where I can
[ __ ] smoke a stick after I love that
kind of nice big picture of [ __ ] no
no no Winston Churchill or some [ __ ]
would be wonderful
all right but on a man if identity we
own our shout out is that Linton
Churchill it's Iron Maiden all right
with Winston Churchill is one I think
Aces High believed it was all right go
[ __ ] yourself I'll check in on you in
Thursday